NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WE WILL
CLOSE WELL. READ THE ROLL
ACOSTA.
AG WE ARE CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRO.
BURKE.
GABRIELLE.
CALDERON.
RADIO.
SO BONTA S..
CHAO.
CHAVEZ.
GEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI TO.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG.
RAZOR.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE.
LIMON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN THIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
WHERE SU CHI?
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
STONE.
BERMAN.
TING.
VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WORD.
MISTER SPEAKER
WHERE'S THE REFERENCE
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER TO
PLEASE RISE.
TODAY'S INVOCATION WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
GOVERNOR STEP.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
UNTIL IT WAS THE BLUE SKY
VALENTINE'S WHENCE THE
AFTERNOON.
WE WERE ALL HORRIFIED TO WATCH
THE NEWS FROM PARKLAND FLORIDA.
UNFOLDING BEFORE US LIFE.
FROM MARGIE STONEMAN DOUGLAS
HIGH SCHOOL.
SEVENTEEN DEAD.
FIFTEEN INCHES.
IN NINETEEN YEAR OLD SUSPECT IN
CUSTODY.
I HEARD A LOCAL OFFICIAL SPEAKS
SAYING.
THE VIOLENCE HAS TO.
ANOTHER SAID.
YOU MUST MAKE SURE THIS NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN.
BUT CNN REPORTED THAT THIS WAS
THE EIGHTEEN SCHOOL SHOOTING
THIS YEAR.
LAST YEAR.
I SHARED MY RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTION.
WHAT IS EVIL?
AS I'D BEEN TAUGHT AND COME TO
UNDERSTAND.
EVIL IS ESSENTIALLY SELFISHNESS
SO GREAT.
THAT HUMAN BEINGS COMPLETELY
LOSE PERSPECTIVE.
AND FEEL THAT THEIR VIEWS
THEIR BELIEFS AND THEIR DESIRES.
ARE THE ONLY THINGS WOULD BE OF
CONCERN.
AND WHAT THEY WANT.
IS ALL THAT MATTERS.
THE LOSE TOUCH WITH THE HUMANITY
THAT WE ALL SHARE.
AND THE CARE ONLY ABOUT
THEMSELVES.
WHETHER IT IS THE OPEN VIOLENCE
OF TERRORISTS.
THE SILENTLY INTO OUR DOMESTIC
ABUSE.
OR LONE GUNMAN TAKING INNOCENT
LIVES AT OUR SCHOOL.
SELFISHNESS AMPLIFIED INTO
ACTION.
IS POISON.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF WISDOM
AND REASON.
IT IS SENSELESS.
THAT IF OPEN OUR SESSION TODAY.
WITH LOVING KINDNESS FOR ALL
FAMILIES.
WE HAVE LOST LOVED ONES
DEFENSIVE VIOLENCE.
AND WITH LOVING GRATITUDE.
FOR ALL WHOSE EFFORTS AND
SACRIFICES.
ARE DEDICATED TO MAKING OUR
WORLD.
A BETTER PLACE.
NUMBER ONE. WITH GRATITUDE AND
KINDNESS BEYOND WORDS.
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE WHICH TODAY WILL BE
LED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE CEMENT AT
SEVENTY.
MOST THAT'S CALDERON MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON.
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND DEFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. AS WELL AS WAS
WEBER WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND.
AND WEBER JUST.
WITHOUT OBJECTION
SHALL BE THE ORDER
AND AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEMS EIGHT THIRTY
ONE S. C. R. FIFTY SEVEN
CANNELLA FROM THE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE TO.
BUSINESS IN THE DAILY FILE ITEM
TO WILL BE PASSED.
ITEMS THREE SUITS SIX
WILL BE CONTINUED ITEM SEVEN
WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM EIGHT
HR SEVENTY FIVE.
MR CLERK PLEASE READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN ANOTHER'S
RELATIVE TO BLACK ISSUE MONTH.
THANK YOU.
MISTER HOLDEN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. IT'S A
PLEASURE TO STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LET LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
AS I RISE TO PRESENT H. ARE
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH RECOGNIZES
FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
AS BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH WAS
ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED AS NEGRO
HISTORY WEEK AND NINETEEN TWENTY
SIX MY DOCTOR CARTER GOODWIN
WOODSON. AND THE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE STUDY OF NEGRO LIFE AND
HISTORY.
WITH THE INFLUENCE OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND A SUBSEQUENT
EMBRACE OF THE BLACK IDENTITY
NEGRO HISTORY WEEK EXPANDED TO
THE ENTIRE MONTH OF FEBRUARY. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
THIS YEAR THE THEME FOR BLACK
HISTORY MONTH IT'S AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN TIME OF WAR.
MEMBERS CAN I HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
AVERAGE AMERICANS HAVE MADE MANY
SUBSTANTIAL CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
MILITARY SINCE THE REVOLUTIONARY
WAR.
THIS MONTH WE HONOR THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO HAVE MADE BRAVE
SACRIFICES TO PROTECT THIS LAND
OF FREEDOM INCLUDING THE FIRST
AFRICAN. TO THE FRAT FIRST
OUTGOING AMERICAN TO SHED BLOOD
IN THE REVOLUTIONARY WAR AGAINST
BRITISH RULE CRISPUS ATTUCKS.
AN AFGHAN AMERICAN SEAMEN AND
SLAVE.
THE ROLE OF AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
TIME OF WAR IS ESSENTIAL TO THE
PROGRESS WE HAVE ACHIEVED AS A
NATION.
WE ALSO MUST REMEMBER THAT
DESPITE THESE BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN FIGHTING FOR THE FREEDOM
OF ALL AMERICANS.
AFRICAN AMERICANS WERE FACING A
DIFFERENT FIGHT HERE AT HOME.
ESSENTIAL HUMAN RIGHTS AND CIVIL
LIBERTIES WERE BEING DENIED TO
THE VERY INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
FIGHTING TO HELP IMPROVE. THE
LIVES OF OTHERS.
AND.
FOR HISTORY FOR US TO PROGRESS
AS A PEOPLE. WE MUST UNDERSTAND
OUR HISTORY.
BLACK HISTORY IS SO INTRICATELY
ENTWINED WITH AMERICAN HISTORY
WE COULD AND SHOULD SPEND EVERY
MOMENT AND EVERY MONTH
HIGHLIGHTED IN HONORING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS. OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY.
AS CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I STAND BEFORE YOU
AS A RESULT OF THE RESERVE
RELENTLESS EFFORTS.
THE REVOLUTIONARIES WHO CAME
BEFORE ME.
MANY BLACK MEN AND WOMEN FOUGHT
AND SACRIFICED TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN LEADERS.
LIKE PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
ACTIVISTS ANDLEGISLATORS
INCLUDING THE AUDIBLE FREDERICK
MADISON ROBERTS.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MARKS THE
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
HONORABLE FREDERICK IN ROBERT'S
BECOMING THE FIRST. AFRICAN
AMERICAN ELECTED TO SERVE IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
ROBERT'S FACE BIGOTRY.
HATRED.
AND ANALYSTS DOUBT DURING HIS
CAMPAIGN BUT STILL ROSE
VICTORIOUS.
OUR COMMITMENT OF EVENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA MUSEUM LAST NIGHT WAS
ENLIGHTENED EXPERIENCE.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THE
LIFE OF A REVOLUTIONARY WITH YOU
TODAY AS DESCRIBED BY HIS
DESCENDANTS.
MADAM SPEAKER PERMISSION TO RIP
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE AFRICAN PROVERB IT TAKES A
VILLAGE TO RAISE A CHILD IS
DEFINITELY TRUE IN THE SUCCESS
STORY. OF FREDERICK ROBERTS.
HE GREW TO BE AN EXCEPTIONALLY
ACCOMPLISHED INDIVIDUAL
SUPPORTED BY AN UNUSUAL VILLAGE
THAT VALUED FAMILY. EDUCATION
COMMUNITY PUBLIC SERVICE AND
CIVIL RIGHTS.
FOR TO ROBERT'S FAMILY PROVIDED
HIM WITH THE STRONG VALUES AND
WORK ETHIC FOR HIS SUCCESSES
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE AND EVEN
SHAPE THE LEGACY HE WAS TO LEAVE
BEHIND. AFTER HIS DEATH.
DOCUMENTATION.
BY THE GETTING WORD ORAL HISTORY
PROJECT BEGUN BY DOCTOR DIANE
SWAN RIGHT.
MS LUCIUS CENTER STATEN THEM AS
BEVERLY GRAY. MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT FREDERICK MADISON ROBERTS
WAS INFLUENCED BY HIS MATERNAL
GRANDFATHER MADISON HEMINGS.
THROUGH HIS MOTHER ELLIN WAYS
HIT MEANS ORAL HISTORIES
RECORDED INTERVIEWS AND WRITTEN
DOCUMENTS WERE COLLECTED FROM
THE DESCENDANTS. OF ENSLAVED
FAMILIES THAT LIVED AT
MONTICELLO DURING THE THOMAS
JEFFERSON LIFETIME.
MADISON HEMINGS A SLAVE AT
MONTICELLO.
IT HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED COULD
READ AND WRITE.
HIS RECOLLECTIONS.
IN A NIGHT EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE NEWSPAPER REFERRED TO
SALLY HEMINGS AS HIS MOTHER AND
THOMAS JEFFERSON.
THE PRESIDENT THE THIRD
PRESIDENT UNITED STATES.
AS HIS FATHER.
MADISON. WAS SALLY HEMMINGS AND
THOMAS JEFFERSON SECOND TWO
YOUNGEST CHILD AND IS CREDITED
WITH BEING THE HEMMINGS FAMILY
HISTORIAN.
A COMMUNITY LEADER AND CIVIL
RIGHTS ADVOCATE ALL OF HIS ADULT
LIFE HE PASSED ON FAMILY HISTORY
TO HIS CHILDREN.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY
FIVE.
AND I AM EXTREMELY HUMBLED.
IN THE FACT THAT MY DISTRICT IS
THE DISTRICT FROM WHICH.
MISTER ROBERTS RAN.
HE IS ALSO.
UP LA HIGH ALUMNUS SOA MINE
HE IS ALSO U. S. C. TROJANS. AS
SO AM I.
SO AND RECOGNIZING.
THAT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
MARKS THE ONE HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN ELECTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
FREDERICK MEDICINE ROBERTS I
ASKED PERMISSION TO CONTINUE
TO READ AN EXCERPT FROM HIS
BIOGRAPHY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MADISON HEMINGS YOUNGEST
DAUGHTER ELLA HEMMINGS WAS
FREDERICK ROBERTS MOTHER.
HELLO WAY WHALES HEMMINGS
ROBERTS WAS FIVE FOOT TEN TALL
FAIR SKIN WITH BLUE EYES.
SHE HAD A SHARP WIT.
ANDREW JACKSON ROBERTS FRED
ROBERTS
FATHER WAS A VERY DARK SKINNED
MAN.
WHO WAS A GRADUATE OBERLIN
COLLEGE BAY WERE NEXT DOOR
NEIGHBORS AND EVENTUALLY
MARRIED?
AND.
I'VE KNOW WE GET THIS WRONG
SCHILIT KOTTE.
OHIO FREDERICK MEDICINE ROBERTS
WAS BORN IN JULY VOTE DAY.
SPENT THE FIRST YEARS OF HIS
LIFE THEY'RE LIVING CLOSE TO THE
HEMMINGS FAMILY WERE SEEDS OF
FOR A LIFELONG INTEREST IN CIVIL
RIGHTS WAS PLANTED.
THE ROBERTS FAMILY MOVED TO LOS
ANGELES IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT ONE FREIGHT WAS SIX YEARS
OLD HE HAD A SISTER MYRTLE
ESTELLE AND A BROTHER WILLIAM
GILES.
FURTHER GREW UP IN LOS ANGELES
IN THE MIST OF A LAND BOOM WERE
LESS THAN THREE PERCENT OF ITS
POPULATION WAS AFRICAN AMERICAN.
LATER AS THE AFTER AMERICAN
POPULATION GREW ALONG WITH
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION FREDERICK
MADISON ROBERTS WHICH SPEAR HAD
PROTESTS AND BOYCOTTS IN LOS
ANGELES TO ROBERT'S FAMILY WAS
VERY ACTIVE IN THE BAPTIST
CHURCH.
FREDERICK ROBERTS ATTENDED LOS
ANGELES HIGH SCHOOL WHEN IT WAS
DOWNTOWN AT ITS ORIGINAL
LOCATION AT FOUR FIFTY NORTH
GRANT.
FREDERICK ROBERTS BECAME LOS
ANGELES HIGH SCHOOLS FIRST KNOWN
GRADUATE OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
DESCENT.
HIS YOUNGEST BROTHER ALSO
GRADUATED FROM LOS IN WHAT LOS
ANGELES HIGH SCHOOL.
FREDERICK LATER ENJOYED TELLING
HIS GRANDCHILDREN ABOUT THE
ROBERTS FAMILY DONATING MONEY
FOR A NEW HIGH SCHOOL. AND I'LL
ON OLYMPIC BOULEVARD BECAUSE
PUBLIC EDUCATION WAS IMPORTANT
TO HIS FAMILY.
FREDERICK ROBERTS BEGAN COLLEGE
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MAJORING IN PRE LAW.
HE GRADUATED FROM COLORADO
COLLEGE WHERE HE WAS A FOOTBALL
STAR.
HIS JOB EXPERIENCE INCLUDING
INCLUDED.
TAX ASSESSOR
GOLD PROSPECTOR
SCHOOL PRINCIPAL AND NEWSPAPER
OWNER EDITOR.
FRED'S FATHER ESTABLISHED THE
FIRST.
BLACK OWNED MORTUARY IN LOS
ANGELES AJ ROBERTS AND SONS AT
TWELVE BEEN LOS ANGELES STREETS
IN NINETEEN OH NINE.
THE MORTUARY LATER MOVE TO
CENTRAL AVENUE. IT WAS A FAMILY
BUSINESS THAT BELIEVED IN
COMMUNITY SERVICE.
MOST OF FAMILY WORKED THERE
ADDED AT.
AT AND IT AT ANY GIVEN TIME
AFTER AMERICA COMMITTEE
APPRENTICES INCLUDED. JOSEPH
SPALDING AND LAMAR HILL WHO EACH
ONE ON TO ESTABLISH THEIR OWN
SUCCESSFUL FUNERAL BUSINESSES
AND LOS ANGELES.
THEY CONSIDER THEMSELVES MEMBERS
OF THE ROBERTS FAMILY.
FRAZIER ROBERTS REMAIN CLOSE TO
HIS MOTHER ALL HIS LIFE.
AND KNEW HE WAS THE GREAT
GRANDSON OF THOMAS JEFFERSON.
A PASSED THIS INFORMATION ON TO
HIS DAUGHTERS GLORIA AND
PATRICIA. THEY SHOULD THEY
SHARED IN INTERVIEWS.
HE TOLD THEM ABOUT THEIR
ANCESTORS AND THEY WERE THEY AND
THAT THEY WERE AMERICANS.
OF AFRICAN DESCENT.
I TERM HE PREFERRED TO NEGRO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND.
IN THE SAME TRADITION OF MY
COLLEAGUES ASK PERMISSION TO
CONTINUE TO READ FROM MISTER
ROBERTS
A BIOGRAPHY WRITTEN BY HIS
FAMILY WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AS A NEWSPAPER EDITOR IN
BUSINESS OWNER ROBERTS BECAME A
PROMINENT LEADER IN THE GROWING
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN
LOS ANGELES.
HIS WIFE PEARL SAID IN A GETTING
WORD INTERVIEW.
HE WAS AHEAD OF HIS TIME IN RACE
RELATIONS
HE DID NOT LIKE THE WORD NEGRO.
HE WANT TO EXPRESS THE IDEA THAT
WE WERE AMERICANS AND SHOULD BE
TREATED AS AMERICANS.
IN THIS PAPER THE NEW AGE
DISPATCH
WHICH HE OWNED AND EDITED UNTIL
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT.
HIS WIFE PEARL SAID HE USE THE
TERM AFRICANS AMERICANS OF
AFRICAN DESCENT.
WHEN OTHER PEOPLE SAID ANOTHER
NEGRO WAS LYNCHED.
HE SAID ANOTHER AMERICAN OF
AFRICAN DESCENT WAS LIST
LYNCHED.
THE ROBERTS FAMILY WAS ACTIVE IN
THE METHODIST CHURCH WHERE HIS
SISTER MYRTLE ES DALE PLAYED THE
ORGAN AND PIANO AS SHE DID IN
THE FAMILY FUNERAL BUSINESS.
FREDERICK ALSO BECAME A MEMBER
OF THE IN DOUBLE ACP AND THE
URBAN LEAGUE.
ESTABLISHED EARLY IN THE IN THE
NECK IN THE TWENTIETH CENTURY TO
WORK FOR POLITICAL AND CIVIL
RIGHTS.
LATER IN IN CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY RECORDS HE IS ALSO
LISTED AS THE FIRST MEMBER OF
THE BLACK CAUCUS.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
YEARS AGO.
ROBERTS WAS ELECTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY FROM
THE SICK AND SIXTY SECOND
DISTRICT AS A REPUBLICAN. AND A
HARD FOUGHT CAMPAIGN DURING
WHICH IS CHIEF RIVAL MADE RACIAL
SLURS AGAINST HIM USE INCLUDE
CALLING HIM THE INWARD.
WHILE IN OFFICE ROBERT SPONSORED
LEGISLATION TO ESTABLISH
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA UCLA
AND IMPROVE PUBLIC EDUCATION.
MAKING EDUCATION MORE ACCESSIBLE
WAS ONE OF THE FREDERICK ROBERTS
FAVORITE ACHIEVEMENTS ACCORDING
TO HIS NEPHEW ELMER ROBERTS.
HE PROPOSED SEVERAL CIVIL RIGHTS
AND ANTI LYNCHING MEASURES IN
THIS HOUSE.
IN JUNE NINETEEN TWENTY TWO HE
BECAME THE BOOK HEAP HE WELCOMED
THE BLACK NATIONALIST LEADER
MARCUS GARVEY TO LOS ANGELES AND
WROTE IN HIS PARADE CAR.
ROBERT WAS THROUGH ROBERTS WAS
RE ELECTED REPEATEDLY AND SERVED
A CONTINUOUS TOP TOTAL OF
SIXTEEN YEARS.
BECOMING KNOWN AS THE DEAN OF
THE ASSEMBLY.
HE WAS A FRIEND OF EARL WARREN.
THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA WHO
BECAME CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE OF
THE UNITED STATES.
IN NINETEEN IN THE NINETEEN
THIRTY FOR MID TERM ELECTIONS
ROBERTS WAS DEFEATED. BY
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE.
AUGUSTA'S HAWKINS.
FOLLOWING THE NINETEEN THIRTY
FOUR CALIFORNIA SIMPLY DEFEAT
ROBERT SLANDER UNSUCCESSFULLY
FOR THE UNITED STATES HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES ON TWO DIFFERENT
OCCASIONS. UNTIL LYNN NO AFRICAN
AMERICAN HAD YET BEEN ELECTED TO
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA IN THE U.
S. CONGRESS.
ON THE EVENING OF JULY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO A FEW DAYS
AFTER ATTENDING THE NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO REPUBLICAN CONVENTION.
AND TWO WEEKS BEFORE HE WAS TO
BE NAME A FOREIGN AMBASSADOR.
ROBERTS THE STAIN SERIOUS
INJURIES WHEN HIS CAR HE WAS
DRIVING WAS STRUCK BY ANOTHER
VEHICLE NEAR ME AND IN IN THE
NEAR HIS LOS ANGELES HOME.
HE DIED THE FOLLOWING AFTERNOON
AT THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
GENERAL HOSPITAL AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY TWO.
HE WASN'T TURN IN EVERGREEN
CEMETERY AND HE WAS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE PEARL AND TWO DAUGHTERS
GLORIA AND PATRICIA ROBERTS.
TODAY ONE OF MADISON OH HINMAN'S
DESCENDANTS IT SAID COULD BE IN
THE INDICATIVE OF ROBERTS A
LEGACY.
THEY SAY WE SIMPLY ACCEPT THE
WHO WE ARE WHAT WE ARE.
WE LOOK LIKE THE RAINBOW
COALITION WHEN WE GET TOGETHER.
FREDERICK MADISON ROBERTS FELT
THAT WE ARE ALL AMERICANS SHOULD
BE TREATED WITH RESPECT A SUCH
AND SHOULD WORK TIRELESSLY
TOWARD HIS GOAL.
WE WANTED YESTERDAY EVENING.
.
TO HAVE THE MEMBERS OF THE
FAMILY A WITH US IN THE HERE
TODAY AS WELL.
BUT WE ALSO HONOR TO HEAR THE
HISTORY OF THIS MAN.
YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING AS I
POINTED OUT THE OTHER DAVID ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY WE SOMETIMES
COME TO THE FLOOR AND WE TALK
ABOUT HISTORY REMIND OURSELVES.
OF THIS MONTH CELEBRATION.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE WE CAN TELL YOU
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW IN A
MONTH ABOUT AFRICAN AMERICANS.
BUT WE HOPE TO DO A COUPLE
THINGS ONE TO SPARK YOUR
INTEREST AND MAKE YOU FEEL SO
INADEQUATE. THAT YOU REALLY
DON'T KNOW OUR HISTORY THAT WE
DON'T KNOW OUR COMPLETE HISTORY
AND AS A RESULT OF NOT KNOWING
IT WE SHOULD BE STRIVING EVERY
DAY TO KNOW MORE AND MORE ABOUT
OURSELVES.
ROBERTS HISTORY REMINDS US OF
JUST HOW HARD IT WAS FOR A
PERSON TO WORK TO GET ELECTED.
EVEN IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THERE WERE NO OTHER ROLE MODELS
FOR HIM TO LOOK TO.
HE HE FELT HE WAS AN AMERICAN HE
KNEW HE WAS AN AMERICAN
AND HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE IN THIS
HOUSE IN ON THIS FLOOR.
AND AS A RESULT HE SERVICE
SIXTEEN YEARS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MAKING SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES AND MOST OF US DIDN'T
ALWAYS NAME UNTIL WE CAME IN
DISCOVERED IN THIS RECORD BOOK.
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO WAS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WHO PAVE THE
WAY FOR OTHER AFRICAN AMERICANS
TO COME AND OTHERS TO COME TO
THIS HOUSE.
SO IT SHOULD REMIND US OF JUST
HOW RICH OUR HISTORY IS
AND HOW MUCH WE DON'T KNOW. AS I
POINTED OUT LAST NIGHT AFTER
HAVING STUDIED AND TAUGHT
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISTORY FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS.
EVERY DAY I LEARN SOMETHING NEW.
THAT MAKES ME FEEL INADEQUATE
THAT I DIDN'T HAVE THE EDUCATION
I NEEDED WITH ALL THE DEGREES I
HAVE.
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE DEPTH
OF THE DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
TO APPRECIATE EVERY CALIFORNIA
BUT NOT ONLY THAT NOT ONLY HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO US WOULD JUST
THINK ABOUT HE KNEW EARL WARREN.
AND WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF EARL WARREN TO
THE WHOLE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
PROBABLY WAS INFLUENCED BY HIS
FRIENDSHIP AND RELATIONSHIP WITH
THIS GENTLEMAN. THAT HE KNEW ON
A PERSONAL LEVEL TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE WAS SOME HUMANITY VIA
THAT NEED TO BE SOME FAIRNESS
AND SOME SOME EFFORT TO TRY TO
CREATE SOME SENSE OF EQUALITY
FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL.
AND SO WE NEVER KNOW EVERY DAY
WHO WE MEET.
BUT WE KNOW THAT EACH ONE OF US
A MAKING HISTORY IN SOME VERY A
POSITIVE WAY. AND WE HAVE TO
WORK VERY HARD TO ACCOMPLISH
THAT.
SO BLACK ISSUE JUST SIMPLY
BECAUSE IT CONTINUES TO REMIND
ME THAT NO I CAN'T LEARN IT ALL
IN A MONTH.
BUT I DISCOVERED I HAVE LEARNED
IT ALL IN SIXTY NINE YEARS BUT
I'M STILL A STUDENT OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN HISTORY I'M STILL A
STUDENT CALIFORNIA HISTORY I'M
STILL A STUDENT OF U. S. HISTORY
IN WOMEN'S HISTORY. AND WHEN WE
DO NOT GIVE ALL OF US THE SPACE
AND THE RECOGNITION THAT WE
NEED.
IT LESSENS EACH AND EVERYONE OF
US
SO ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK CAUCUS
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
ALLOWING US TO READ HIS HISTORY.
OUR HISTORY THE HISTORY OF THIS
ASSEMBLY BUT ISSUES THAT WERE
FOUGHT A HUNDRED YEARS AGO ON
BEHALF OF ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
WE SHOULD TAKE PRIDE IN THIS
LEGACY. THAT HE LEFT FOR US AND
THAT WE KNOW EACH ONE OF US THEY
AND ON THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
HE'S MADE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR US TO VOTE
I OWN HR SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER CAUCUS
AYE TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF HR SEVENTY FIVE LET ME FIRST
START BY WISHING EVERYONE A
HAPPY LUNAR NEW YEAR.
THE MOST FAVORED OF ANTI HAVE
DURING THE MONTH OF FEBRUARY MY
DISTRICT IS AN EVENT THAT
CELEBRATES BLACK HISTORY MONTH
AND LUNAR NEW YEAR. AND IT'S NOT
JUST MY FAVORITE EVENT BECAUSE
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE COMING
TOGETHER AND WE'RE SHARING
CULTURE AND WORK SHARING SOCIAL
TIES.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US
BECAUSE THE STRUGGLES OF OUR
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY HAVE
FOLLOWED. THAT OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
BEFORE THE HISTORY OF THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT AND THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN INTERNMENT.
WE FOLLOW THE HISTORY OF SLAVERY
AND JIM CROW LAWS.
BEFORE THE HISTORICAL TRIUMPHS
OF OUR ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
WE FOLLOWED THE HARD FOUGHT
FIGHT OF DECADES OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE I WOULD
APPEAR TO BE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
BUT FOR THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. I MOVED TO SAN
FRANCISCO IN MY TWENTIES TO WORK
FOR THE CIVIL RIGHTS LEGAL
ORGANIZATION ROOTED IN THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
AND AS AN ASIAN AMERICAN AND I
THINK I SPEAK ALSO FOR OUR
LATINO COLLEAGUES ARE LGBT
COLLEAGUES AND OTHERS. I DON'T
THINK I WOULD BE STANDING HERE
ON THIS FLOOR
BUT FOR THE STRUGGLES AND
TRIUMPHS OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WHEN IT CAME TO VOTING
RIGHTS WHEN IT CAME TO LOOK
TOWARD REFORMS. WHEN IT CAME TO
WHAT CIVIL RIGHTS RITUALLY
ABOUT.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS NOT ONLY
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO THINK
ABOUT OUR HISTORY BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO THINK ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
AND WHERE WE NEED TO GO.
THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE TRUE
EQUALITY.
WE DON'T HAVE TRUE QUALITY WHEN
IT COMES TO HEALTHCARE.
WHEN IT COMES TO EDUCATION.
WHEN IT COMES TO INCOME. WHEN IT
COMES TO HOUSING. WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH REMINDS US.
THAT THE IDEA OF EQUALITY AND
JUSTICE FOR LAWS NOT YET A VALUE
THAT EVERYONE IN EVERY COMMUNITY
SEASON THIS IS WHY. I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY
FIVE AND I HOPE WE CAN HAVE A
UNANIMOUS VOTE FOR TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY
FIVE. DESIGNATING FEBRUARY IS
BLACK HISTORY MONTH BLACK
HISTORY MONTH IS ABOUT
CELEBRATING BOTH THE LEGACY AND
THE FUTURE OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY WE RECOGNIZE
IN FRONT. INFLUENTIAL LEADERS TO
HELP PAVE THE WAY FOR EQUALITY
AND JUSTICE AS WELL AS LEADING
IN SO MANY FIELDS THAT HAVE
AFFECTED. ALL ASPECTS OF BOTH
THE UNITED STATES AND THE WORLD.
TODAY WE RECOGNIZE THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS AND YET THERE WERE
MANY AFRICAN AMERICANS WHO LACK
RECOGNITION DESPITE THEIR TALENT
THEIR SKILLS THEIR BRAVERY THEIR
PERSEVERANCE.
AND ALL OF THOSE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
THESE ARE OFTEN AMERICANS WHO
MADE SACRIFICES IN SOCIETAL
CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE FACE OF
ADVERSITY AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE LEADERS AND THE MEMBERS HERE
ON THE FLOOR. TO EDUCATE US AND
SHARE WITH US SOME OF THOSE
STORIES.
THE. BLACK HISTORY CONTINUES TO
BE MADE.
AND THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
PEOPLE WITH ALL BACKGROUNDS HAVE
RALLIED BEHIND BLACK LIVES
MATTER. MOVEMENT ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF BLACK LIVES MATTER
WE SHOULD GARZA. WAS RAISED IN
MARIN COUNTY AND IS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE.
BLACK LIVES MATTER STARTED AS A
SOCIAL MEDIA MOVEMENT TO END
VIOLENCE POLICING THE OPPRESSION
OF BLACK PEOPLE AND RACISM. IN
UNITED STATES AND IT'S NOW
RECOGNIZED GLOBALLY.
ACCORDING TO MS GARZA THE REASON
THAT SHE CREATED BLACK LIVES
MATTER IN THIS WAY IS BECAUSE
SHE WANTED TO BUILD A SENSE OF
EMPOWERMENT.
AND SELF DETERMINATION.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH ALLOWS US TO
REFLECT ON OUR COUNTRY'S PAST
AND REMINDS US. THAT THERE IS
MORE WORK TO BE DONE. I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
PROFFERING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAVANT
AS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
AT ALL THE PRETTY CAUCUS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY FIVE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOUR
PARTY SEVEN DIFFERENT POCKETS
AS.
FEBRUARY CELEBRATES A REMARKABLE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN LEADERS WHO ARE MADE
COMMENDABLE CONTRIBUTIONS
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISTORY IN
SPITE OF OVERWHELMING OBSTACLES.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
AMERICANS TO RECOGNIZE AND
CELEBRATE AFRICAN AMERICANS WHO
HAVE MADE A TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE IN THE FIGHT FOR
CIVIL AND HUMAN RIGHTS FOR
PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE.
IN FACT THE EVENT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE AS THE BEGINNING OF
THE LGBTQ CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
AT STONEWALL INN IN ON JUNE
TWENTY EIGHTH NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE WAS PREDOMINATELY LED BY
BLACK AND LATINO QUEER AND
TRANSGENDER YOUTH.
DESPITE BEING AT THE HEART OF
OUR NATION STRUGGLE FOR CIVIL
AND SOCIAL RIGHTS MANY AVERBAKH
LGBTQ ICONS ARE OFTEN INVISIBLE
OR ERASED. FROM BOTH LGBT Q. AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISTORY.
ONE EXAMPLE BEING THE FORMATION
OF A BLACK LESBIAN CAUCUS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. THIS GROUP
OF INDIVIDUALS OFFERED BLACKENED
MEDINA LESBIANS AN ALTERNATIVE
FROM WHITE MALE DOMINATED
POLITICAL ORGANIZATION IN NEW
YORK.
AND THE DISCRIMINATORY
ATMOSPHERE OF BOTH URBAN GAY AND
LESBIAN BARS.
NOW FORMALLY KNOWN AS THE
AFRICAN ANCESTRY A LESBIAN
UNITED FOR SOCIAL CHANGE PEACE
ALSO SO SISTERS GALVANIZED
AROUND ISSUES PERTINENT TO
LESBIAN WOMEN.
NOT JUST DOT THE TRULY
DEMONSTRATED WHAT IT MEANS TO
PERSIST.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE HIGHLIGHT
IN HONOR THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
OUR BLACK LGBTQ ACTIVISTS.
WHO HAD FOUGHT FOR SO MANY
DECADES THEY HAVE MADE
SACRIFICES SO THAT WE CAN ENJOY
THE RIGHTS THAT WE DO TODAY?
I AM PROUD TO STAND ON BEHALF OF
THE LGBT CAUCUS IN AUSTRIA I
SUPPORTER ON HR SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALLY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS I. I RISE TODAY TO
PROBABLY SUPPORT HR SEVENTY FIVE
RECOGNIZING FEBRUARY AS BLACK
HISTORY MONTH.
WELL WE SHOULD NOT LIMIT OUR
CELEBRATION OF THE HISTORY AND
AMERICANS TO A SINGLE MONTH. IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE STOP EVERY
FEBRUARY TO REFLECT ON THE FACT
THAT MANY FOR MANY YEARS THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS.
TO OUR COUNTRY WERE LARGELY LEFT
OUT OF OUR TEXTBOOKS AND
IGNORED.
THIS YEAR I LEARNED A LITTLE
ABOUT FREDERICK ROBERTS THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN TO SERVE
HERE IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
A SIMILAR ROBERTS
WHO I SHOULD NOTE WAS A
REPUBLICAN.
SERVED IN THIS BODY FOR SIXTEEN
YEARS.
HE SPONSORED LEGISLATION
LEGISLATION TO ESTABLISH UCLA.
HE WORKED AT TO EXPAND THE USE
OF SCHOOL TEXTBOOKS IN SCHOOLS
ANY SERVE TO AND WAS A CHAMPION
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS IN THE CAPITAL.
I COURAGE EVERYONE TO USE BLACK
HISTORY MONTH TO LEARN A LESSON
OF OUR PAST IT CONTINUE WORKING
TOGETHER. TOWARD EQUALITY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS IN THIS NATION.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE IN HOUSE FOR NIVEAU.
THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MOST MEMBER
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU METASPECTRUM MEMBERS I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS
IN HONOR OF BLACK HISTORY MONTH
AS WE SPEAK A LOT OF THIS
CHAMBER ABOUT HISTORICAL FIGURES
AS WELL WE SHOULD ABOUT THE
LESSONS THAT WE'VE LEARNED. AND
I THINK IT'S A IT SPECIALLY
FITTING THAT WE TALK TODAY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE MILITARY TO
AN AFRICAN AMERICANS HISTORY OF
OF SERVICE.
AS A AS A VETERAN I CAN TELL
YOU BASIC TRAINING WHEN. YOU
WEAR A BLACK AND BROWN TOGETHER
IN THE MILITARY BEING A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF OF OF INTEGRATION AT
AN EARLIER STAGE.
AND BASIC TRAINING WE ALL CRIED
THE SAME TEARS WILL CRICHTON
CALLED ON THE SAME GROUND AND
WILL SERVE VERY PROUDLY
TOGETHER.
AND I WAS PROUD TO SERVE
ALONGSIDE AFRICAN AMERICANS I
WAS PROUD TO HAVE HAD MOST ALL
OF MY SUPERVISORS.
BOTHA ELECT ADMIN ELECTED A
NCOS AS WELL AS OFFICERS BE
AFRICAN AMERICAN FIND SOLDIERS
WHO WERE PROUD TO SERVE THEIR
COUNTRY FROM ALL OVER THE. MALL
OVER THAT THE.
THE STATE'S WHEN WE.
I WORK AT WALTER REED MEDICAL
CENTER KIMBROUGH ARMY HOSPITAL
BUT BACK IN THE DC AREA WERE A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE HAVE RETIRED.
AND THE RICHNESS OF SERVING THE
VETERANS WHO SERVED BACK THROUGH
WORLD WAR TWO I WAS ALWAYS
HUMBLING.
PEOPLE WOULD COME IN FOR SERVICE
NO WE FAST FORWARD IT TO TO MY
TIME IN ON THE SECOND CITY
COUNCIL A AND THE RICH DIVERSITY
IN STOCKTON. THE LONG HISTORY OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS SERVING IN
ELECTED OFFICE.
IN MY CITY THE TRACY A STRONG
REPRESENTATION OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN ELECTED OFFICE AT
WE ALSO HAVE A VERY RICH
FORMING A BACKGROUND EVERY
SINGLE TO MILE PARADE WHICH IS
OUR LARGEST PARADE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AFRICAN AMERICANS COME OUT ON
HORSEBACK.
AND HAVE THE RODEO RIDERS
ALWAYS BRING UP THE THE BACK SO
WE ARE COVERED ON ALL SIDES BY A
RICH DIVERSITY A AND THEN I FAST
FORWARD TO WHICH YOU ARE YOUNG
BAR YOUNG MAYOR RIGHT NOW.
I'M SURE YOU MIGHT GET TIRED OF
ME TALKING ABOUT HIM BUT I DON'T
THINK WE CAN TALK ABOUT HIM
ENOUGH A AS HE STARTS EVERY
SPEECH YOU'LL ASK DID YOU HEAR
ABOUT THE ROSE THAT GREW FROM
CONCRETE. FROM HIS OWN LIFE ON
SOUTH SIDE STOCKTON BEING RAISED
IN A SINGLE FAMILY HOME.
WITH WITH WITHOUT THE RICHES
BUT THAT ROSE THAT WAS NURTURED
BY A MOTHER AND A GRANDMOTHER
AND AUNTIE WHO TOOK IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO MAKE SURE HE HAD
EVERYTHING HE NEEDED.
IF THE ENVIRONMENT WAS IN
PROVIDING AND THEY WERE
PROVIDING IT WITH HIM.
YOU CAN TURN ON THE NATIONAL TV
AND SEE HIM SPEAKING NOW AROUND
THE COUNTRY AROUND THE WORLD
AFTERTHE CITY OF STOCKTON AND
WHAT WE NEED TO REALLY BE ABLE
TO EMPOWER. YOUNG PEOPLE AND
YOUNG PEOPLE OF COLOR BECAUSE WE
NEVER GET AHEAD MEMBERS WHEN
ANYONE GETS LEFT BEHIND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ON BEHALF OF THE.
LATINO CAUCUS ASPIRIN AYE VOTE
ON HR SEVEN FIVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I ALSO STAND TO FOR VETERANS.
.
AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE SERVED
THIS COUNTRY LOYALLY BRAVELY AND
WELL.
EVEN ONE THE COUNTRY WASN'T
SERVING THEM OF OILY GRATEFULLY
AND WELL.
THEY'VE ALWAYS
HAD TO FIGHT
TO BE ABLE TO FIGHT.
SO STRANGE DICHOTOMY.
AT THE END OF THE CIVIL WAR.
ELEVEN PERCENT OF THE UNION ARMY
WAS AFRICAN AMERICAN.
WORLD WAR ONE.
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND AFRICAN
AMERICANS PARTICIPATED MAINLY A
STEVEDORES AND SUPPLY PEOPLE.
AND THEY ALSO RAN A LARGE CHUNK
OF THE RARE ROOMS.
WITHOUT THAT LABOR WITHOUT THAT
BACKING.
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN IN DEEP
TROUBLE.
AND THEY WERE.
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST GREATLY.
BUT THEY STILL DID THEIR JOB.
STILL DID IT.
WORLD WAR TO WAS EVEN MORE
PROBLEMATICAL TO SOME EXTENT.
ONCE AGAIN TWO THIRDS OF THE
SUPPLY LINES WERE RUN BY AFRICAN
AMERICANS ESPECIALLY THE RED
BALL EXPRESS WHICH PUT HIGH
PRIORITY PARTS AND. BACK UP TO
KEY UNITS
THE NINETY SECOND DIVISION.
BUFFALO SOLDIERS
FOUGHT.
AND FOUGHT.
HAD UP PER CAPITA HIGHER
CASUALTY RATE MUCH LIKE THE
JAPANESE FOR FOR TO COMBAT
REGIMENT.
THEY FOUGHT.
AND WHEN THEY WENT BACK HOME.
LEADING GET MUCH OF A PARADE.
THE BIG BREAKTHROUGH CAME.
BY PRESIDENT.
TRUMAN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE.
WHEN WE FULLY DESEGREGATED THE
MILITARY AND OF COURSE THE
ADMIRALS AND GENERALS PREDICTED
THE MILITARY WOULD COLLAPSE.
WELL THAT BRINGS THIS TO
VIETNAM.
IN VIETNAM.
I WILL GUARANTEE YOU BULLETS AND
SHRAPNEL DID NOT CHECK THE
MELANIN LEVEL OF THE VICTIM.
EVERYONE GOT HIT EQUALLY.
AND AFRICAN AMERICANS HAD A
HIGHER PER CAPITA CASUALTY RATE.
THAN ANYONE ELSE.
TWO THEORIES THEIR NUMBER ONE.
THEY WERE ALWAYS PUT AT THE
FRONT.
WHICH I BELIEVE I'VE OBSERVE
THAT NUMBER TO.
THEY ENDED UP IN MOST OF THE
COMBAT UNITS
FOR THE FIRST TIME THEY WORK
JUST REGULATED TO DEMEAN
SUPPLIES.
AND WHEN THEY GOT A CHANCE TO
FIGHT. THEY FOUGHT.
THAT BRINGS US TO TODAY.
TWELVE PERCENT OF THE POPULATION
IS AFRICAN AMERICAN SIXTEEN TO
SEVENTEEN PERCENT IS IN THE
MILITARY IN A REASON FOR THAT
IS.
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY.
YOU ARE TREATED EQUALLY IN THE
MILITARY AFRICAN AMERICANS KNOW.
THAT IS A TICKET LIKE FOR ME OUT
OF POVERTY. AND TO EDUCATION.
SO I GREATLY SUPPORT HR SEVENTY
FIVE.
GOD BLESS YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
MISTER HOLDEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
A FEW MINUTES SPEAKER. LET ME
JUST ALSO THINK ALL OF OUR MY
COLLEAGUES TO. ROSE TO SPEAK
TODAY AND ASSURE THEIR THEIR
SENTIMENTS IN THEIR THOUGHTS.
ON THIS IMPORTANT DAY.
I KNOW CLEARLY THAT. THE
ESSENCE OF WHAT ALL OF YOU HAD
TO SAY TOUCHES ON ALL OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS WHO. ARE FOLLOW
YOUR THOUGHTS AND YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT DAY THAT IS
ONE THAT WE. ALL RECOGNIZE EVERY
YEAR.
BUT TODAY WHEN WE ASK FOR CO
AUTHORS.
ON THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION.
I WANT YOU TO. TO REALLY FOCUS
ON.
FREDERICK ROBERTS.
BECAUSE WHEN HE CAME HERE HE WAS
THE ONLY AFRICAN AMERICAN HERE.
AND HE BELIEVED AS YOU HEARD
THAT.
SERVING IN THIS
BODY AND PUBLIC SERVICE WAS AN
HONOR.
AND IT WAS ONE THAT HE WAS GOING
TO. TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF.
THAT HE WAS GOING TO ARTICULATE
THE CONCERNS ON THE FRUSTRATIONS
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THE
PEOPLE IN HIS COMMUNITY
EXPERIENCED.
AND LOOK TO HIM TO BE THEIR
TALENT. THEIR THEIR LEADER ON.
SO AS I LOOK AT ALL OF YOU.
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE HERE.
YOU REPRESENT UNIQUE
THE DISTINCT PARTS OF THIS DAY.
YOU COME HERE TO REPRESENT.
WHAT HAS THE VERY BEST IN YOUR
COMMUNITY?
YOUR IDEAS AND YOUR VALUES.
AND WITHIN THIS BUILDING WE TRY
TO INTEGRATE THEM INTO A COMMON
PURPOSE AND DIRECTION.
SO WILL YOU PUSH THE GREEN
BUTTON AND JOIN ON AS A A CO
AUTHOR.
KNOW THAT YOU'RE ALSO
RECOGNIZING SOMEONE WHO CAME
BEFORE US TO.
HAD TO SHOW COURAGE.
AT A SHOW DEDICATION.
HOW TO REPRESENT SILENT VOICES
THAT NEEDED TO BE HEARD?
AND THAT DOES WHILE YOU'RE HERE
AS WELL.
SO COLLECTIVELY WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH SOMETHING.
THAT FREDERICK ROBERTS BELIEVED
AND THAT EVEN THOUGH HE WAS
AFRICAN AMERICAN DESCENT.
HE WAS IN AMERICA.
SO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ON HR SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHOR
MEMBERS. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM. ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM NINE WILL BE
PASS AND RETAIN ITEM TEN ACR ONE
SEVENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
PLEASE READ. SOME CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY ONE BY
SOME REMEMBER EGGMAN OTHERS
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL AFFAIRS HIS
MINISTER CLERK I'M SORRY WE HAVE
GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS.
FROM MELONES ASK MISTER HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AS CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS IT IS A PRIVILEGE
WE JUST HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR A GREAT DEAL OF. THE
BACKGROUND ON FREDERICK ROBERTS
BUT IT'S OUR PLEASURE THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE.
MEMBERS OF HIS FAMILY HERE
TODAY.
THE GRANDCHILDREN OF HIS OWN
HIS BROTHER WILLIAM ROBERTS.
DESCENDANTS OF HIS OF FAMILY AND
WITH THE HELP OF THE MINORITY
FLOOR LEADER. AND THE FRIEDMAN
PURE WE WERE ABLE TO MAKE
CONNECTIONS TO THE FAMILY AND
THAT ARE HERE WITH US TODAY AND
AS PART OF. THE ROBBERS LINEAGE
THEY TO OUR DESCENDANTS
SALLY HEMMINGS AND PRESIDENT
THOMAS JEFFERSON THE AUTHOR OF
THE DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE.
ROBERSON SENTENCE ARE AND THEY
ARE HERE ON THE FLOOR WITH US
AND WE LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THEM
NOW.
ELLEN WELLS PUBLIC HOT IN IT.
GREAT NIECE OF FREDERICK
ROBERTS.
ROBIN JOHANNA ROBERTS GREAT
NIECE OF FREDERICK ROBERTS.
AND KAREN WILLARD GREAT NIECE
GREAT GREAT MATES
OF FREDERICK ROBERTS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING. THE DISSIDENTS.
PRODUCTS
OKAY MOVING BACK TO SECOND
READING THE CLERK WILL PLEASE
READ HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTY
NINE.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOVING OUT ITEM TEN ACR ONE
SEVENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY ONE BY
SOME REMEMBER EGGMAN OTHERS
RELATIVES IN NATIONAL
CHARACTERISTIC.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
YOUR RECOGNIZE
THINK ABOUT SPEAKER I RISE BEE
ON BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
UP FOR ACR SEVENTY ONE WHICH IS
A HONORING. WOMEN'S.
CARE GIVERS DAY A.
WE DO A LOT ON ON RECOGNIZING
PEOPLE WITH SPECIAL DISEASES IN
SPECIAL ILLNESSES AND A WE DO A
LOT OF WORK TO A TO HONOR THOSE
AT THAT OVERCOME FROM SOME OF
THE DISABILITIES THAT THEY MIGHT
HAVE. BUT WE DON'T TALK ENOUGH I
THINK ABOUT THE CARE GIVERS
BUT THERE ARE FORTY THREE
MILLION A UNPAID CAREGIVERS OUT
THERE WHO ARE TAKING CARE OF
PARENTS WHO ARE TAKING CARE OF
SIBLINGS WERE TAKING CARE OF
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILDREN. AS A
SOCIAL WORKER I WORKED IN
HOSPICE AND HOME HEALTH AND.
EVERY DAY WAS HUMBLED WHEN I
WOULD GOING TO PEOPLE'S HOMES TO
TO PROVIDE A SUPPORT FOR
SOMEBODY SICK BUT ALSO A WHOLE
FAMILY THAT WAS SURROUNDING THEM
OFTENTIMES GIVING UP THEIR
DREAMS GIVING UP THEIR DESIRE SO
THEY COULD. CARE FOR THAT PERSON
AT HOME SO.
I ASK THAT WE ALL THINK ABOUT
NOT JUST THE FOLKS THAT ARE ARE
ARE OVERCOMING STRUGGLES BUT
THOSE THAT ARE HOME TAKING CARE
OF THOSE PEOPLE AS WELL. AYE THE
MAJORITY BEING WOMEN BUT A LOT
OF MEN TOO SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
VOTING ON ACR ONE SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE AS A PROD CO AUTHOR OF ACR
ONE SEVENTY ONE. ACR ONCE OF
ANYONE IS A WELL DESERVED
TRIBUTE TO ALL THE UNSUNG HEROES
WHO DAY IN AND DAY OUT. CARE FOR
THE RELATIVES PARTNERS FRIENDS
AND NEIGHBORS THE AMOUNT OF
PATIENCE COMPASSION AND EMPATHY
IT TAKES FOR A PERSON TO BECOME
A CARE GIVER CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED.
AS NOTED IN THIS ACR ABOUT FORTY
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
CAREGIVERS IN OUR COUNTRY
PROVIDE UNPAID CARE TO ADULTS
AND CHILDREN.
THE MAJORITY OF WHICH OR WOMEN
IN THEIR MID FORTIES TO MID
SIXTIES.
CAREGIVERS ARE HUMBLE SERVANTS
WHO OFTEN.
OUR TASK WITH PUTTING EVERYONE'S
NEEDS BEFORE THEIR OWN.
THURMOND IN WOMEN WITH HEARTS OF
GOLD WHO SO OFTEN GIVE MORE THAN
THEY EVER RECEIVE.
FOR ALL OF THESE REASONS AND
MORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND ASK FOR YOU TO CALL
A FOR FOR ALL TO CALL AND THINK
ANY CAREGIVERS IN YOUR LIFE
TODAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA YOUR
RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ALLOW
THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON FOR HAVING US ALL TAKE
A MOMENT. TO ESPECIALLY THANK
OUR CAREGIVERS AS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY AGING A LONG TERM CARE
COMMITTEE. I'VE LEARNED FAR TOO
MUCH ABOUT HOW SO MANY.
ARE STRUGGLING TO AGE BOTH WITH
GREAT HEALTH AND PEACEFULLY AT
HOME THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
WITHOUT THE AID OF OF THOSE IN
THEIR HOMES THESE CAREGIVERS.
NOT ONLY BUT THE QUALITY OF
LIFE OF LITERALLY.
HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF OUR
AGED A BE IN JEOPARDY BUT.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THESE
CAREGIVERS ARE LITERALLY SAVING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BILLIONS
IN DOLLAR BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IN TERMS OF COSTS AYE WHETHER IT
BE HEALTH CARE BECAUSE HOUSING
COSTS EMERGENCY ROOM BECAUSE OF
THESE CAREGIVERS ARE NOT ONLY
GOOD.
FOR US PHYSICALLY BUT THEY'RE
GOOD FOR US MORALLY AND SERVED
WITH SUCH GREAT COMPASSION AND
AGAIN I WOULD URGE EVERYONE TO
CERTAINLY VOTE I ON THIS
IMPORTANT. RECOGNITION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST RULED
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
YES PLEASE.
QUICKLY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR COAL
OFFICE ONLY.
MEMBERS THIS ROSE FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE ALL
OF THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING
NOW TO ITEM ELEVEN HR SEVENTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL PLEASE
READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
RELATIVE TO EARN INCOME TAX
CREDIT WEEK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH RECOGNIZES
THIS WEEK AS CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT WEEK.
IT'S THAT TIME OF YEAR AGAIN TAX
SEASON.
USUALLY AT THIS TIME WE HEAR
MANY MANY COMPLAINTS AND
GRUMBLES ABOUT WHAT IS
CALIFORNIA STATE DOING WITH OUR
TAX DOLLARS.
BUT TODAY I HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS
TAXIS AND PROVIDES FINANCIAL
HELP TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS.
THANKS TO ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL BUT UNDER USED
PROGRAMS THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
TOOK A MOMENTOUS STEP FORWARD ON
BEHALF OF WORKING FAMILIES BIKES
JOINING TWENTY SIX STATES AND
THE DISTRICT OF CAMILLA COLUMBIA
BY ESTABLISHING THE STATE'S
EARNED INCOME TAX.
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT IS
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS
TO LIVE FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
OUT OF POVERTY.
IN ITS FIRST YEAR THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT BOOSTED THE
INCOME OF NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS PROVIDING
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. IN REFUNDS.
HOWEVER IN CALIFORNIA ALONE AN
ESTIMATED TWO BILLION OF STATE
AND FEDERAL EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT HAS NOT BEEN USE MEMBERS
I WANT YOU TO REALLY. THINK
ABOUT THAT THERE IS A CREDIT OUT
THERE THAT CAN HELP CONSTITUENTS
IN YOUR COMMUNITY AND IT'S NOT
BEING USED SO AS WE KNOW WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE OUR LOCAL CITY
COUNCILS. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
OUR COMMUNITY CENTERS. KNOW
ABOUT THIS AND CONTINUE TO DO
OUT REACH.
MY OFFICE AS MANY OTHER OFFICES
HAVE WORKED WITH OUR COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO CREATE OUTREACH
FOR AWARENESS OF THE PROGRAM AND
EVEN HELP OUR CONSTITUENTS WITH
TAX FILING ASSISTANCE IN
WORKSHOPS. THIS MAKES A
DIFFERENCE MEMBERS THE
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCE WILL HELP
WORKING CALIFORNIANS BRING IT
ECONOMIC SECURITY TO THEIR LIVES
WITH FUNDS THAT CAN GO TOWARD
REPAINT DEBT.
BUILDING SAVINGS OR BUYING GOODS
AND SERVICES THAT SUPPORT
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
TAX CREDITS OR ASSOCIATED EVEN
WITH BETTER OVERALL OUTCOMES OF
CHILD'S HEALTH AND EDUCATION I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION FOR IN EARNED INCOME
TAX. CREDIT WEEK AND TO
ENCOURAGE ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
SPREAD THE WORD ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT RESOURCE TO THOSE.
WHO NEED IT MOST I ASKED THAT
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS?
THINK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
HERE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY SEVEN
ITHANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FULLERTON FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT IS
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS
IN AMERICA. AS NOTED EARLIER TO
LIFT FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY.
TO LIVE TO FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY.
BY STEPHAN I HAVE BEEN HARD AT
WORK FOR THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS
HELPING TO GET THE WORD OUT
ABOUT THIS TAX CREDIT. AS FORTY
ONE PERCENT OF THOSE LIVING IN
MY DISTRICT DISTRICT FORTY SEVEN
ARE ELIGIBLE AND I ASSUME THAT
THAT THE SAME WOULD BE TRUE FOR
MANY OF YOUR DISTRICTS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THROUGH THE HARD
WORK AND DEDICATION OF THE KELLY
I TO SEE FOR ME ORGANIZATION.
AND THE COALITION THAT WE'VE
BUILT.
SPECIFICALLY IN MY DISTRICT MY
CITIES ON MY NON PROFITS OF GOLF
SIGNED RESOLUTIONS.
AGREEING TO GET THE WORD OUT TO
THE OR TO THE TO THE COMMUNITY.
WE KNOW THAT WE CAN TRIPLE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT HAS BEEN
RETURNED TO THE INLAND EMPIRE
THROUGH THIS CREDIT.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR
ALL OF US
TO TALK TO OUR CONSTITUENTS SO
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED IT
MOST.
CAN HAVE MORE MONEY IN THEIR
POCKETS
YOU KNOW THIS FOR MY THIS REASON
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
LIKE AMOUNT SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR
SEVENTY SEVEN.
THE EITC WERE HOW CALIFORNIA'S
OUT OF POVERTY AND FIND
FINANCIAL STABILITY. THIS
PROGRAM IS MORE THAN A SIMPLE
TAX CREDIT. FOR MANY FAMILIES
THIS MEANS MORE NUTRITIOUS FOOD
ON THE TABLE. MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CHILDREN AND MORE MONEY
SUPPORT HEALTH CARE ARE GORGEOUS
BODY TO SPREAD THE WORD ABOUT
THIS IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. A STRONG URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON HR SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION MCCORKLE PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS.
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS RULE IS FOR CO
FOR.
CLERK WILL BE CLIP PLEASE CLOSE
THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEMS TWELVE AND THIRTEEN PASS
AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
TODAY HERE IN THE CHAMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS YES MADAM SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES OF IN ADDITION TO
ARE HONORING OF.
BOB ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERTS
THE. CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS IS ALSO RECOGNIZING
THE BLACK STUDENT UNION OF THE
WILLIE L. BROWN MIDDLE SCHOOL IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
ON SATURDAY JANUARY TWENTIETH.
OF THE CALIPHATE CAST AT CAL
STATE FRESNO.
I BLACK MINDS MATTER SPOUSE
STATEWIDE COMPETITION WAS HELD.
AND SCHOOLS FROM THE BAY AREA
AND ALL AROUND CAME TO
PARTICIPATE IN A BLACK MINDS
MATTER COMPETITION.
WILLIE L. BROWN JUNIOR MIDDLE
SCHOOL WON THE COMPETITION
BEATING OUT THE HIGH SCHOOL
TEAMS FROM THE REGION.
THE BLACK STUDENT UNION GROUP
WAS CALLED THE CULTURE KEEPERS.
AND THEY'RE HONORING THEIR
HERITAGE AND THEIR CULTURE.
IT IS INTERESTING TODAY THAT AS
WE HONOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERTS
WHO WAS VERY INVOLVED IN ARE
TRYING TO PROMOTE ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE.
THAT WE TALK ABOUT THE PAST OF
THE THINGS HE DID IT. BUT IN
PLANNING THAT SEEDS WE NOW TALK
ABOUT THE PRESENT AND THE FUTURE
IN THE STUDENT FROM THE WILLIE
L. BROWN MIDDLE SCHOOL.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY ELISA
BROWN WHO WAS THE BLACK STUDENT
UNION PRESIDENT HE'S A EIGHTH
GRADER.
IT'S EASY TO IN IS IDEA WILSON
WHO'S THE BLACKSTONE UNIT
SECRETARY HE'S AN EIGHTH GRADER.
MONEY ANGEL SHORT WAS THE BE
ISSUE HISTORIAN EIGHTH GRADER.
ARMY BRIANNA WOULD DANIELS WAS A
BLACK STUDENT UNION VICE
PRESIDENT SHE'S AN EIGHTH
GRADER.
JABBAR HARVEY WHO'S A BLACK
STUDENT UNION MEMBER HE'S A
SIXTH GRADER.
AND SINCERE BRIAN WHO WAS A
BLACK STUDENT UNION MEMBER WHO'S
A SIXTH GRADER. THERE ALSO HERE
WITH THEIR ADVISORS MACHON
MAHOMET AND A TALK SHOW HERE ON
AND THEIR PRINCIPAL CHARLESTON
BROWN. WE WANTED THESE TO SEE
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE DEMONSTRATED ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE DURING BLACK HISTORY
MONTH. AND THEY BEAT UP A HIGH
SCHOOL TEAM THESE EIGHTH AND
SIXTH GRADERS REAP THE HIGH
SCHOOL TEAM IN THE BLACK MINDS
MATTER COMPETITION SO WE WANTED
TO PRESENT THEM TO THE FLOOR
THIS MORNING. AND THANK THEM SO
VERY MUCH FOR COMING.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
WANT TO JOIN OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
DIEGO IN WELCOMING.
THE VERY BEST AND BRIGHTEST.
FROM THE NEXT GENERATION.
I LIVE IN THE BABY NEIGHBORHOOD
AND.
GO AND.
I SOME TWENTY THREE YEARS AGO MY
SEAT WAS REPRESENTED BY NONE
OTHER BUT. WILLIE BROWN.
IN OUR FORMAL ASSEMBLY SPEAKER.
HAS OBVIOUSLY HAD ENORMOUS
IMPACT ON OUR STATE BUT
PARTICULARLY IN OUR CITY WE WERE
WE NAME THIS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
AT SOARED THIS MIDDLE SCHOOL
AFTER OUR FORMER SPEAKER AND
OUR.
FORMER LEADER OF OUR STATE AYE
AND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THE
STUDENTS REPRESENT THE NEXT
GENERATION OF WHAT CHANGES ABOUT
WHAT ACTIVISM IS ABOUT WHAT
VISION IS ABOUT. I HOLD IN MY
HAND THE REPORT.
THAT THEY HAVE PUT TOGETHER ON
THE IMPACT OF JUNK FOOD ON
STUDENTS AND STUDENT HEALTH AND
THE FUTURE A HEALTH CARE OF OUR.
OF OUR NEXT GENERATION I JUST
WANT TO THANK THEM FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ARE AND LOOK FOR TOO
MANY THINGS THAT WE KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GOING ACCOMPLISH. IN THE
YEARS TO COME.
THANK YOU.
AND WELCOME STUDENTS
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR CERTAIN CURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR SKINNER ANOTHER'S
MOTIVES CALIFORNIA GIRLS AND
WOMEN IN SPORTS WE.
THANK YOU THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROWING
TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO.
MEMBERS TODAY'S THE DEADLINE TO
INTRODUCE BILLS I AM ORDERING
THE DEATHS TO REMAIN OPEN UNTIL
FIVE PM OR UNTIL THE LAST BILL
IS RECEIVED. THE PURPOSE OF BILL
INTRODUCTIONS.
AND MEMBERS SATURDAY IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MELENDEZ'S BIRTHDAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELENDEZ.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FEBRUARY NINETEENTH
HOLIDAY PRESIDENT'S DAY FEBRUARY
TWENTIETH FLOOR SESSION AT ONE
PM IN THE ABSENCE OF A JOB
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A JOURNEY MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
SHE BELIEVED IN THAT WE SHOULD
BE ALWAYS FIGHTING. FOR THOSE
VOICES WHO. DON'T MAKE IT TO THE
CAPITAL.
FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO NEED OUR
HELP BECAUSE THEY'RE WORKING.
YOU JOBS AND DON'T HAVE TIME.
TO MAKE ALL THE GOVERNMENT
MEETINGS THAT WE HAVE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
AND IF IT EVER CAME TIME FOR
SOMEONE WHO.
YOU NEED IS SOMEONE.
FOR AN EXTRA HAND OR HELP SHE
WAS ALWAYS ONE OF THE FIRST
PEOPLE. TO VOLUNTEER.
ONE OF THE FIRST PEOPLE TO LEND
A HAND. IT ONE OF THE FIRST
PEOPLE.
TO ALWAYS
GIVE SOMETHING.
OF HERSELF.
SHE BATTLED.
THE WAY THEY YOU EXPECT HER TO
BALLOTS SHE FOUGHT.
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN
UNFORTUNATELY.
LIKE ALL BLACK MESA MANY OF THE
STRUGGLES.
SHE IT FORCEFULLY.
FINALLY LOST THE STRUGGLE.
THERE WE WILL DEFTLY MISTER.
WELL WE MISS HER PRESENCE IN THE
OFFICE WHEN MR PRESENCE IN THE
BUILDING. BUT. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO REPRESENT HER SPIRIT. THROUGH
THE WORK THAT WE DO. AND
THROUGH.
THE FEELING IN THE CARING THAT
THE WORK IS NOT ABOUT. MONEY OR
MOVING MONEY THE WORK IS ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
CHANGING.
LIVES THAT WE ARE DEMONSTRATING.
A DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
IN THAT WE ARE FIGHTING FOR
THOSE PEOPLE. WHO WILL NEVER
EVER MAKE IT TO SACRAMENTO?
BUT THAT I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF SOUND
MICHELIN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO RISE IN
ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
OF SALAMEH'S SHOW. A LOW
CELEBRATION LOGAN OF.
SO I'VE KNOWN SALAMEH'S YOU'RE
PROBABLY FOR FORTY YEARS.
SHE WAS ONCE A STUDENT SAN
DIEGO STATE.
BUT ALSO AN ACTIVE MEMBER IN
THE SENEGAL COMMUNITY.
I KNEW HER MOTHER WHO WAS ALSO
AN ACTIVIST A SOCIAL WORKER
ACTIVISTS IN SAN DIEGO I MET
WHEN I FIRST CAME TO SAN DIEGO.
AND DURING HER LIFETIME SHE'S
ALWAYS BEEN IN QUEST FOR
KNOWLEDGE FOR TRUTH FOR JUSTICE.
TO WORK TO NOT ONLY IN SAN
DIEGO BUT MOVED TO LOS ANGELES
WHERE SHE WORKED WITH MY LANA
CARANGOIDES. AND THE US
ORGANIZATION OUGHT TO TRY TO
BRING JUSTICE AND FAIRNESS OF TO
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
US SHE WAS A COMPASSIONATE WOMAN
WHO MOVED BACK TO SAN DIEGO
BECAUSE HER MOTHER WAS SUFFERING
FROM LUNG CANCER.
SHE WAS HER MOTHER'S CARE GIVER
UNTIL HER MOTHER'S DEATH.
SHE ALWAYS ONE TO COME AS
POINTED OUT TO THIS HOUSE TO
THIS PLACE.
AND SHE FOUND IT QUITE AN HONOR
TO BE ABLE TO WORK IN THE
ASSEMBLY IN ANY CAPACITY. A VERY
SHARP WOMAN BUT ALWAYS ONE OF
TREMENDOUS OF JOY. SHE ALWAYS
HAD A SMILE ON HER FACE WHEN I
TOLL OF MY COLLEAGUES IN SAN
DIEGO THAT SHE PASSED TO SIT ON
MY GOODNESS.
SHE WAS MY RAY OF SUNSHINE
EVERYDAY I CAME TO WORK ON THE
SIXTH FLOOR WHEN I WAS ON THE
SWIM TEAMS ON THE SIXTH FLOOR.
SHE SAID SHE THOUGHT SHE WAS THE
ONE THAT ALWAYS SMILED
SHE ALWAYS HAD SOMETHING GOOD TO
SAY TO EVERYBODY SHE ALWAYS KNEW
THAT THAT BE A SOLUTION TO ANY
PROBLEM THAT ANYONE HAD. AND WAS
ALWAYS WILLING NOT ONLY TO TELL
YOU THE SOLUTION BUT HELP YOU
FIND IT AND HELP YOU WORK
THROUGH.
A A TREMENDOUS WOMAN. EVEN IN
HER ILLNESS WHEN I VISITED HER A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
SHEWAS MORE CONCERNED ABOUT ME
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THE
WORK WE WERE DOING WHAT WANTED
TO KNOW THOSE THINGS.
BEING HERE IN THE CAPITAL OPENED
UP A WHOLE WORLD FOR HER HER
SISTER WHO WAS OUR CARE GIVER TO
THE END. TALK ABOUT HOW THEY
LOOKED AT THE CAL CHANNEL ALL
THE TIME.
AND I'D BE SOMETIMES MAKING
PRESENTATIONS ON THIS FLOOR AND
I GET A TEXT FROM SALAMEH'S IS
SAYING I LOVE WHAT YOU SAID IT'S
SO GREAT. SHE WAS ALWAYS
ENCOURAGING EVERYONE TO BE THEIR
BEST.
AND UP AND SHE THOUGHT THIS
WOULD THIS BATTLE OF CANCER WITH
SUCH GRACE AND STYLE.
HER BE NOTE EVERYONE WHO CAME
INSTALLED INSPIRED WHEN THEY
LEFT THEIR HER HOME BECAUSE SHE
WAS ALWAYS TRYING TO GIVE THEM
SOMETHING GOOD TO THINK ABOUT.
AND SOMETHING GOOD TO LIVE FOR.
IT WAS QUITE A LOSS TO THE
COMMUNITY TO LIEU SALAMEH'S SHE
BECAUSE SHE WAS SO UNSELFISH IN
HER TIME. AND HER AND HER SPACE
BUT THE ONE THING ALSO I I
SOMETIMES HAVE TO REMIND US IN
THIS HOUSE IS THAT. YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT HEALTHCARE.
AND ONE OF THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES IN LIFE WAS TO BE
SICK AND NOT HAVE HOPE HERE.
SHE WAS VERY BLESSED SHE FELT
EVERY DAY THAT SHE HAD WORKED IN
THIS HOUSE FOR THE TIME THAT SHE
DID.
BECAUSE IT GAVE HER A HEALTH
CARE AND THAT WAS ONE THING SHE
DIDN'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT WILL
I GET TO GET TO A DOCTOR WILL I
GET THE MEDICATION I NEED WHAT I
GET THE KIND OF TREATMENT THAT I
NEED. AN EVERYDAY SHE TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THAT WAS A
BLESSING IN HER LIFE TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE HEALTH HERE THE POOR
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
HEALTH CARE. SO THAT WHEN YOU'RE
BATTLING THESE MONSTERS OF LIFE
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
CAN YOU AFFORD TO THE GOOD
FIGHT.
YOU CAN HAVE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
OTHER THINGS SO SHE WILL BE
SORELY MISSED IN THIS COMMUNITY
AT THIS HOUSE.
SHOULD BE SORELY MISSED IN SAN
DIEGO BUT IT IS CLEAR THAT WE
WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER THE GIFTS
THAT SHE BROUGHT WHICH WAS
SUNSHINE AND HAPPINESS THAT
OPTIMISM AND ENCOURAGEMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR THAT
WE JOIN IN MEMORY OF SALAMEH'S
TO LOGAN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES THE DESK
TO BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO RETURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS ARE MEETING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
HOBIE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MISTER GLORIA MOVES AND MISS
WEBER SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL TUESDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTIETH AT ONE PM